il a amassé des dizaines de millions de
dollars en arnaquant de riches
collectionneurs voici l'histoire de
rudyan l'expert en V qui vendait des
fausses bouteilles pendant des années il
a fabriqué de toutes pièces des grands
CR des bouteilles qui peuentarement
atteindre des pris astronomique jusqu'à
plus de 10000 € l'homme mélangeit de
très bons vins et les faisait passer
pour des crus très anciens il est sous
le coup de plusieurs plaintes et risque
jusqu'à 100 ans de prison même pas
imaginer que ce serait la plus grosse
escroquerie sur le vin que le monde a
jamais connu
[Musique]
salut à tous cette semaine dans la
grande Histoire j'avais envie de vous
parler d'un escroc peut-être l'un des
plus grands faossair qu'on ait jamais
connu son nom Rudy curniawan ça ne vous
évoque peut-être rien mais pendant près
de 10 ans il a vendu en tout impunité
des fausses bouteilles de grand vin à
des collectionneurs fortunés jusqu'au
jour où il s'est fait démasquer par un
vigneron français nous sommes le 25
avril 2008 à New York la maison de vente
aux encher ha cur Maryland candit une
institution centenaire et respecté
organise une vente de vins prestigieux
dans un restaurant de
manattan des bouteilles à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de dollars sont
mises en vente parmi elles des grands
cru de Bourgogne comme la roman et Conti
et des closint NIS des années 40 50 et
60 de la maison ponceau nous n'avons
commencé à produire cette appellation
particulière qu'en 1982 donc forcément
là il y a ce qu'on appelle un hic et
c'est c'était le début de l'histoire
quoi prévenu quelques jours avant la
vente Laurent ponceau contacte le
commissaire priseur pour faire retirer
ses bouteilles de la vente aux enchères
peu convaincu par son interlocuteur il
s'envole pour New York je me suis montré
je resté bien debout tout le monde m'a
vu il y a eu un grand Brouis dans la
salle parce que les gens m'ont reconnu
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là il y a ces vins
c'est bizarre et tout et au moment le
commissaire prisire voyant que j'étais
là était obligé de dire à la demande du
du producteur et avec l'accord du
propriétaire des bouteilles nous allons
retirer toutous les 20 penseceaux de la
vente on m'a dit que le propriétaire de
ces vin était Rudy
knew Rudy curniawan est une somité dans
le petit monde feutré des amateurs de
vin un cercle de richissimes
collectionneurs qui n'hésite pas à
dépenser des sommes astronomique pour
s'offrir les millésimes les plus rares
et les plus prestigieux vous pouvez
trouver facilement jusqu'à 50000 dollars
pour une bouteille de roman Conti d'une
année mythique on dira que la moyenne
est plutôt entre 10 et 20000 dollars
pour des bouteilles un peu anciennes au
début des années 2000 le marché des vins
rares est en pleine explosion aux
États-Unis les ventes aux enchères
s'accumulent et les bouteilles de Grand
Cru s'arrachent à prix d'or
2002 et 2007 ce marché passe de 90
millions à 300 millions de dollars un
domain très lucratif notamment pour les
spéculateur et c'est là que va faire son
apparition
rudyan d'origine chinoise Rudy kurnwan
s'appelle en réalité zen wangyong né en
Indonésie en 1976 il émigre aux
États-Unis avec un visa étudiant à la
fin des années 90 et s'installe dans la
banlieue de Los Angeles il a découvert
probablement à un moment donn de façon
totalement en fortuite que les grands
vin se vendaient très cher et que ça
pouvait peut-être être une un moyen de
de venir justement un Américain riche au
début des années 2000 Kwan étudie
l'unologie en autodidacte se spécialise
en vin français plus particulièrement
les grands crus de Bourgogne qui sont à
l'époque moins côtés que les Bordeaux
sur le marché américain repéré pour ses
qualités de goûteur exceptionnell le
jeune étudiant connaît alors une
ascension fulgurante dans le monde des
amateurs de vin certains le croient même
doté du don de supergûteur un talent
rare qui lui permettrait de ressentir
les saveurs de façon bien plus intense
la seule qualité que je puisse trouver à
Rudy Kwan c'est d'avoir une mémoire
incommensurable sous la fausse identité
de Rudy kurniawan il raconte être
l'héritier d'une riche famille
indonésienne le jeune étudiant parvient
à s'introduire dans un club de riches
collectionneurs californiens appelé les
de Bourgogne un club grâce auquel
il peut développer son réseau et vendre
des vins anciens car kurniawan a sur
possédé une cave de plus de 5000
bouteilles qu'il appelle lui-même la
cave magique sa force a été de se mettre
bien avec ces gens-là de devenir le
copain le le finalement le gourou
presque de de de tout du tout Hollywood
puisque c'est là c'est là où il a eu
tous ses clients ciawan mène une vie de
millionnaire dans un quartier upup de
Los Angeles il porte des costumes de
luxe roule en voiture de sport et
s'offre des œuvres d'Andy waroll et de
Damian HST dans les ventes aux enchères
il se fait remarquer en gardant la main
levée pour surenchérir et remporter
presque tous les lots j'avais entendu
parler d'un d'un d'un jeune asiatique
qui achetait pour un demi million de
dollars voir un million de dollars de
vin par par mois qui faisait des soirées
qui menaient des vins extraordinaires
j'en avais entendu parler en 2004 il
rencontre John Capon le commissaire
priseur de la prestigieuse maison
d'enchère new yorkaise àur Meral
andandit grâce à Capon ciawan intègre un
nouveau cercle de collectionneurs les 12
hommes en colère il existe mais comme
partout dans le monde des petits clubs
fermés que j'appelle des clubs décadents
dans lequel on peut dépenser en une
soirée 2 à 300000 dollars de Pinard je
dis Pinard à dessin parce que à ce
moment-là ils savent même pas ce qu'ils
boivent chez les 12 hommes en colère la
coutume veut que chaque membre se trouve
un surnom Rudy ciawan en a de docteur
Conti et Mister 47 il était fanatique du
vin de la romané Conti et Mister 47
parce que c'est un mésime mythique à
Bordeaux et que il avait aussi des tas
de vin de de ce mésim là avec Capon ils
organise en 2006 une vente aux enchères
qui rapporte 10 millions de dollars
quelques mois plus tard ils en organise
une deuxième qui rapporte cette fois-ci
24 millions de dollars un record
historique pour un seul vendeur rudy
curniawen est alors au sommet de sa
gloire mais revenons au début de
l'histoire en 2008 lorsque Laurent
ponceau interrompt la vente aux enchères
à New York le lendemain il est invité à
dîner par curniawan et Capon dans un
grand restaurant j'ai posé la question
assez vite à peine à peine la pare au
but j'ai dit bon alors ils viennent d'
c'est vin et là les deux ont plongé le
nez dans l'assiette en bredouillant on
sait pas on achète tellement de vin il
faut qu'on vérifie alors là j'ai compris
que il me bourrait le mou pour être pour
être franc et quand on achète des vins
quand on a des vins comme ça avant on
sait d'où ils viennent Laurent ponceau
décide de mener l'enquête sur Rudy
curniawan il part sur ses traces à Los
Angeles puis en Asie du Sud-Est plus
particulièrement en Indonésie son pays
d'origine j'ai fait mes investigations
tout seul pendant 2 ans et à un moment
donné j'ai été appelé par le FBI qui
savait que je faisais des investigations
pour savoir si je pouvais devenir leur
conseiller m' travaillé main dans la
main pendant encore 2 ans
pendant ce temps-là le milliardaire
américain Bill cock découvre que ses
bouteilles censé avoir appartenu à
Thomas Jefferson l'un des premers
présidents des États-Unis sont en
réalité des
fausses il décide alors de faire
expertiser sa cave de 43000 bouteill et
en 2009 il attaque en justice kurniawan
et la maison d'enchère hacker qui
l'accuse de lui avoir vendu 200 fausses
bouteilles pour plus de 2 million de
dollars alors que les soupçons
sépécisent sur l'origine du vin de Rudy
kiawan celui-ci peine à rembourser ses
nombreuses dettes notamment auprès de la
maison de vente aux enchères hackur à
qui il a emprunté 10 millions de
dollars le 8 mars 2012 rudwan est
finalement arrêté par le FBI lors de la
perquisition à son domicile les agents
découvrent un V able laboratoire des
fausses étiquettes des faux cachets de
cire des faux tampons et des recettes
pour imiter des grands crus français
tout y est pour conffectionner de
fausses bouteilles de vin rare à partir
de vin ordinaire je ne donnerai pas les
méthodes de Rouy mais il a trouvé une
méthode assez simple c'est pas difficile
non c'est pas difficile faut être très
précis il faut il faut avoir le
matériel la matière première
et on
peut
lors de son procès Rudy Kwan PL non
coupable il risque 100 ans de prison le
suspect reste muique sur ses secret de
fabrication et ses éventuels
compli il était pas possible qu'il soit
tout seul il était pas non plus possible
qu'il fasse qu'il produisent les fausses
bouteilles tout seul il avait des
petitesain
derrière
rudwan sera finalement condamné à 10 ans
de prison et a remboursé 28 millions de
[Musique]
dollars depuis l'affaire Kwan la
traçabilité des bouteilles de vin
prestigieux a été renforcé mais les
fausses bouteilles vendu par le faer
indonésien continue de garnir les caves
des collectionneurs on va revoir sortir
dans les ventx encher des fausses
bouteilles de rou très de victimes se
sont fait connaître pour ne pas
justement tomber de leur piédestal parce
ce sont souvent des gens célèbres ou ou
riches et donc on a perdu beaucoup
d'argent mais on en a encore assez pour
pouvoir continuer de vivre et donc bah
on on s tait ça c'est assez classique de
de ce milieu de d'hyper riche on va dire
voilà quant à John Capon il n'a pas été
inquiété par la justice américaine il
continue de prospérer dans la vente de
vin prestigieux Rudy kurnwa a lui été
libéré de prison en 2022 avant d'être
expulsé vers l'Indonésie il aurait
depuis repris ses activités dans le
vin merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à dire ce que vous en avez pensé en
commentaire et à vous abonner à la
chaîne brut si vous voulez voir d'autres
vidéos de ce style vous avez le lien de
la playlist en description à très vite